hey youtubers is charlie so a lot of you
guys requested in agents of shield
season 3 video and because this is a
captain america movie year we're going
to see a nice big crossover with the
Avengers so what I'm going to do is talk
a little bit about some of the
storylines they're doing and some of the
characters that they're bringing on so
real quick catch up where we at with
agents of shield right now they just
introduced the idea of the Inhumans they
turn the Terrigen bomb from the comics
that black both sets off to the fish oil
pills of the TV show so that's the easy
segue to Inhumans popping up all over
the place that Coulson has to deal with
it has to track down and try to train or
lock up if they're going to be villains
on the movie side of things we have
civil war brewing and in the comics that
was kind of like a gun control allegory
whereby a young team the New Mutants try
to track down some young villains and it
turns into this massive catastrophe with
a bunch of school children dying that
sparks the national debate that sets off
the superhero Registration Act so a lot
of people are wondering if they're going
to do this new mutants storyline with
like one of Coulson's teams a bunch of
people are going to get killed and
that's going to throw to civil war in
the movies the TV shows already
confirmed that they're doing secret
warriors from the comics but I think
what they're going to do is they're
going to blend that thumb attica Lee
with what happens with the new mutants
leading into civil war well the really
bad news is is that even if the movies
flow from that same type of energy
they're going to be so busy trying to
explain what's going on with all the
characters in the movie that they
probably won't have time to talk about
the TV show a whole lot that's why
whenever the TV shows crossover with the
movies it's always way bigger on the TV
side of things just because they have so
much more time to address story points
the movie has like two two and a half
hours to tell its story and that's it
but you could tell a TV story over the
course of like four or five episodes but
really the point of contention here is
that new inhumans are popping up
everywhere there's a couple of them
they've already confirmed for the TV
show we know we're going to see a
version of the superhero Registration
Act so that means we're probably going
to see a version of the stamford
incident in the TV show just when you
think of name areata vs. nitro setting
off that giant explosion in the comics
think of the project caterpillar people
the sky and Lincoln are going to be
working with if you haven't read the
comics you don't know what the Stanford
incident is it's a bunch of teenage
superheroes in the New Mutants tracking
down some teenage supervillains named
areata one of the New Warriors starts
taunting one of the Super
nitro and he sets off a huge explosion
that kills her a couple other team
members in a bunch of school children
nearby so on the macro scale that turns
into Captain America versus Iron Man on
two sides of the superhero Registration
Act but on the small scale like on the
TV level of things we could see a
speedball tie park he's another one of
the new mutants that renames himself
pennants after the tragedy I know that
name sounds kinda on the nose but you
get the idea it just seems logical that
for like a mid-season finale big WTF
episode they would do something along
the lines of stamford now captain
america civil war the movie will come
right around the last couple of episodes
of agents of shield season 3 like the
back half of the season so by that time
they'll be getting ready to close the
season down they'll be getting ready for
their biggest episodes and one of the
new characters that they've cast is
going to be someone that's working for
the government so I think it's going to
be unlike the other side of the
superhero Registration Act it's
Constance Zimmer you might not recognize
her right away but she's been in a whole
bunch of stuff they didn't say who she's
playing but I'm thinking of her is like
the Norman Osborn hammer type person
basically somebody on the government
side of things that's going to try and
take possession of all of shields assets
in the wake of what happens like Coulson
fails to stop big tragedy so the
government gets involved so that
government person is going to be one of
the new villains of the season although
not an evil villain the evil villain is
really going to be the ward character
he's gonna be one of the big bads of the
season 2 but he'll be that I want to
hurt you type of villain not that I want
to take your toys type of villain what
about supervillains though they have
cast the lash character who is an
inhuman who's just like really upset
with the idea of a bunch of other people
getting to be in humans who he feels
like don't have the right to take in the
Terrigen mists they kind of tease that
plot point in the Inhumans settlement
where it's like it's a very big deal to
take in the Terrigen mists and it's only
very rarely that they create a new one
so think about what happens when fish
oil goes all over the world there's
gonna be in humans everywhere naturally
some of the pre-existing in humans are
going to be really upset with the idea
of like average Joe getting to be an
inhuman if they feel like they don't
have the right to how can superheroes be
special if anybody can be a superhero
it's like it's like the incredible story
line if everybody's special then
nobody's special tell that to a group of
kids one or two you yeah you'll probably
special the rest of you know if you're
not special but moving along to the spin
show a lot of you even asking me about
Marvel's most wanted that says busy like
the Mockingbird show that they're doing
I actually recorded a video about that
but just didn't get around to editing it
I was actually pretty upset with like a
couple of the things that they had
teased about it it just seemed like
there were a couple big logic holes in
the pitch that we got from the network
so it's supposed to be a show all about
bobbi and Hunter they don't want it to
be a direct spinoff they didn't explain
how they're gonna do it without it being
a crossover it could be a prequel I'm
guessing not i think it'll pry end up
being a crossover anyway i think that
the person that was explaining it from
the network just miss quoted some stuff
but instead of just calling it
mockingbird they're calling it Marvel's
most wanted making it sound like it's
going to be a bug hunt like an inhuman
bug hunt I'm totally fine with that idea
adrianne palicki and Nick blood are two
of the best characters on agents of
shield right now which is kind of a bad
thing because the show is losing them
but the show already has too many
characters so it's going to jettison
some people but I think the reason why
they're calling it Marvel's most wanted
is because they want Marvel in the title
they want like that brand recognition so
that people who have absolutely no idea
what's going on we'll just see the name
Marvel and click on it I guess you can't
fault them for that but but usually when
you put like the Marvel title on
something it comes with certain levels
of expectation but here the important
dates show shield is coming back sep
tember 29th that's like the week after
Gotham and a couple other shows like
heroes reborn is the week before that
too most of the TV stuff I do like the
DC stuff and the Marvel stuff is coming
back the last two weeks in September in
the first week in October I know you're
all starting to get really bored because
it's the end of the summer and everybody
has to go back to school but I'm
probably gonna do for my next marble
video is my favorite in human characters
so be sure to subscribe to get that it
does anything that you guys want me to
talk about around the TV shows or the
movies just let me know in the comments
just in case you guys didn't see it we
got a small teaser for what the teams
are going to be during captain america
civil war you can click here to learn
all about that and you can click here
for the Star Wars Episode 7 teaser they
just drop the other day thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you